dermatitis herpetiformis and it's a rash  that people with celiac disease can get  and so that's the autoimmune disorder  caused by gluten so i started  researching celiac disease and i saw  that celiac disease can couple with  other autoimmune disorders and i was  like maybe i just have celiac disease  and that's why i had arthritis so i cut  out gluten and  i probably improved by 10 percent it was  like  a little bit like my skin started  healing it was like interesting and i  thought what are people allergic to  and i thought you know eggs dairy  grains soy i cut out everything i could  think of that i thought maybe somebody  could alert be allergic to and i ended  up with  basically meat certain like pitted fruit  and greens and a certain root vegetables  like parsnips sweet potatoes  and i went down to that diet for a month  and my skin healed  i lost five pounds my arthritis started  to feel better  and so i started getting rid of my  medications